the Donald Trump Justice Department led
by Jeff session has abruptly settled a
money-laundering case with a Russian
real estate company the company in
question is prevas on they've agreed to
pay a six million dollar penalty to
avoid a trial this is a six million
dollar fine for the alleged money
laundering of two hundred and thirty
million dollars by tax fraud this took
place in May sort of sounds cheap right
two hundred and thirty million dollars
in alleged tax fraud and you get away
with a penalty of just six million
dollars and you completely avoid going
to trial seemed a little bit odd in May
but now it is much more concerning
because you know who the lawyer is that
was representing prevas on her name is
wait for it Natalya vessel meets kaya
the same Russian lawyer who we learned
this week met with Donald Trump jr.
Jared Kushner and Paul Manafort to
deliver dirt on Hillary Clinton meant to
help Donald Trump win sort of strange
that if we believe Donald Trump jr.
story that while she promised dirt she
didn't deliver dirt just as things are
starting to heat up we figure out that
she was involved in the settlement for
only 2.6 percent of the allegedly
laundered amount of money I'll give you
the numbers once more because they're so
stunning this was a trial that was set
to happen over two hundred and thirty
million dollars in money laundering they
were able to settle for six million
dollars that's 2.6 percent of the amount
of money allegedly laundered House
Democrats aren't happy they wrote a
letter demanding to know why this was
settled so suddenly and so cheaply a
quote from that letter says quote last
summer Donald Trump jr. met with a
Kremlin connected attorney in an attempt
to obtain information that would
incriminate Hillary earlier this year on
May 12 2017 the Department of Justice
made an abrupt decision to settle a
money laundering case being handled by
that same attorney in the Southern
District of New York we write with some
concern that the two events may be
connected
and that the State Department may have
and that the department may have settled
the case at a loss for the United States
in order to obscure the underlying facts
this attorney is increasingly a
character of interest he or she is
pictured during a Foreign Affairs
Committee meeting hearing about Russia
in 2014
how did she get a front-row seat to this
hearing according to McFaul she was
invited by Republican congressman Dana
Rohrabacher we have a tweet here from
Michael McFaul the ambassador I've been
told that congressman Rohrabacher
invited her to the hearing someone
should confirm with his office he is
also anti sanctions why is that
interesting well congressman Dana
Rohrabacher was one of the two people
mentioned back in remember those leaked
tapes where you had Republican
congressman Kevin McCarthy on audio tape
saying there's two people I think that
Putin pays Rohrabacher and Trump right
very interesting that every aspect of
this is coming full circle and then the
room laughed and he goes no no I'm
serious yeah Paul Ryan said something
about we're not talking about that this
is an off-the-record meeting right and
then people laughed I know I say this a
lot you can't write this stuff at this
point you need a four-hour documentary
just to sort out all the elements of
this story that this particular Russian
lawyer is involved in never mind Donald
Trump well to add another component to
this she might have been in the country
illegally too she was denied a visa in
2015 and then she was on immigration
parole in the early months of 2016
wasn't able to get that visa renewed
that's right and you know we wouldn't
normally bring this up but when you have
the president who goes on and on about
illegal immigration and how we need to
up our vetting procedures because we
just don't know who's coming into the
country and what legal acts they made
can be committing it's completely
hypocritical and it turns out the
illegal acts may be with Trump himself
and the Trump defenders are actually
blaming that entire thing that the
entire immigration status thing on Obama
and it's it's just amazing what's going
on anyway that's the latest very
very disturbing stuff you can talk about
this with us on our reddit discussion
forum at david pakman.com slash reddit
today's program is made possible by taga
dabbe the hosting specialists offering a
range of flexible hosting packages
including dedicated VPS and cloud server
options as well as custom server
solutions and uk-based colocation
services for your business or project
taga dad's web hosting services support
a wide range of customers and businesses
worldwide including bloggers tech
startups financial traders gamers web
developers and more and taga dad has a
really user-friendly interface so you
don't have to worry about being super
tech savvy they can automate almost
everything you need for total ease of
use they are really proud of their team
of expert hosting specialists who are
also their support team 70% of their
business comes from repeat orders and
recommendations with a growing number of
people interested in moving their
businesses and projects to the cloud
taga dab is currently offering our
viewers and listeners a twenty british
pound free credit about twenty four US
dollars to all customers signing up to
give you a chance to try the service
this is a limited availability offer
first-come first-served for viewers and
listeners of the David Pakman show to
take advantage of it go to sign up CAG
adapt calm /td PS and use the offer code
TDPS 20 all one word all lowercase
during account registration